people go to me Francis what do you see
yourself as you see yourself as being
British or Venezuelan I see myself as
being a Londoner because London is the
most tolerant opal and liberal City in
the entire planet because as londoners
we don't care about race gender
ethnicity the only thing that we care
about is that you walk at the correct
[__]
[Applause]
speed I am liberal in Immigration but if
you're a slow Walker [__] off
mate that's a moment pretty Patel should
just pop up and gently guide you out the
door and you'll be saying things like
who my name's Chris I was born in this
country it doesn't matter Chris you're
behaving like a
[Music]
[__]